victoire divise hall n'a que 5 ans elle
vient de tourner son premier film mais
déjà elle obtient le prix
d'interprétation à la mostra de venise
mais elle se retrouve aussi à la tête
d'une polémique qui doit lui échapper
après l'annoncé de son prix sifflé dans
la salle roman polanski président du
jury sera obligé de préciser plus tard
qu'il s'agit d'un vote à l'unanimité
dans ponette le film de jacques doillon
victoire interprète une petite fille qui
ne comprend pas et refuse la mort de sa
mère
mais peut-on réellement parler
d'interprétation pour un enfant de 5 ans
jacques doillon souligne que son actrice
six jeunes soit elle a dû se concentrait
se plier aux normes techniques du cinéma
et ils renvoient la balle mais pas aussi
réussi qu'un enfant de 12 ans la chose
delà de cette pensée d'adultes qui
pensent que un enfant de 4 ans est
quasiment totale ou victoire est une
enfant magie ou la mostra n'a pas osé
donner le lion d'or aduayom mais a tenu
à le récompenser ou le festival vénitien
à vous de faire un joli coup de pub pour
briller un peu plus car un prix
d'interprétation à cinq ans c'est tout
de même du jamais vu